you
hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game from round seven of the 2018
Sinquefield Cup on the white end Magnus
Carlsen and he's paired against Fabiano
Caruana this is the last meeting between
these two before they compete later this
year in November at the World Chess
Championship match I'd look forward as
usual to covering that event there will
be at least seven games played it's a
best of 12 game match so this game
certainly an important one heading into
that big event who if any will have a
psychological edge in this game Caruana
chooses a favorite defense of his
Petrov's
Knight f6 and to be a bit more exact we
enter a variation noted as the
nimzowitsch attack move five-night c3 I
like this approach to the Petrov defence
over the move d5 because it immediately
creates some imbalance a structural one
in this case and because of this change
in the structure there's a change in the
files what is a half opened e-file to
work with note how this has an influence
on the white King's decision we'll see
what that is
soon enough first getting some miners
out black O's King side and white is
prepping for Queen side castles this is
the most important feature in this
position it's an opposite sides castling
position and time as a result is a big
factor ideally both sides would like to
create open lines towards the enemy King
so that the major pieces have quick
access to the enemy King now the way to
do this create open files is to launch
pawns towards the enemy King if there
are two pieces that stick out to me
b-besides the Kings it's the bishops in
this position each you'll know are
within reach of pawns that would like to
move this isn't to say both sides will
be launching pawns in this manner but
you know this is something to certainly
consider these tempo gaining moves so
from here Queen d7 King b1
con FTA vacating the square for the
minor piece the bishop sometimes you
would even do this for a queen night f8
is useful for the bishop some space for
white on the King side Bishop f8 if it's
going forward maybe if g4 is in g5 is in
with tempo it's best to kind of tuck
that Bishop away more space for white at
this point black says you've gone far
enough
h6 now in general in these opposite
sides castling positions you don't want
to move pawns in front of your king it's
justified here you really do not want to
see this pawn get all the way down to h6
that would create a hole on f6 and well
if you want another reason it takes away
blacks favorite flight square from the
king if white is getting in h6 black
doesn't have the square h7 for the king
okay so black plays h6 move 13 and after
Bishop to e2 pop-quiz black to move what
does Cara wanna play next feel free to
pause the video okay this is likely a
difficult test I imagine for many before
I share what this next move is let me
try to anticipate what many of you were
maybe thinking about those of you who
chose to give some consideration to this
moment in the game many of you may have
concluded the rook in the corner isn't
doing anything therefore I'm gonna shoot
I'm gonna play rook to e7 then doubled
rooks in general not a bad idea
but one that does not address what
White's threat is in this position I
really do mean that there is a there's a
threat here the threat is to get into g5
advanced and you'd be surprised how fast
that can hit if you don't make the move
in the game Bishop g4 this is the move
played in a game Bishop g4 if you play
rook e7 Knight h2 is in g4 hits with
tempo g5 is nearby the G file will be
ripped open and the rooks are going to
have a lot of fun on the G file now is
not the time to double rooks but rather
to address this tempo gaining g4 advance
white does that with Bishop g4
light-square bishop tsar exchanged note
that white will have to at some point
waste some time repositioning the Queen
don't want to keep her opposite this
rook all day
black improves the knight white
repositions the bishop similar posts for
the dark square bishop s-- queen c6 at
the moment there are no great forward
moves for the night any black knight
move will throw a punch at the Queen but
there's nothing good c4 is the only one
right now there's an that's an
intersection Square for black White's
okay with this move continues to press
on the Kings side f4 like c4 Queen d3 at
this point it's your white is going to
be faster you know black at this stage
can't say you know what let me just
start throwing pawns here hope for a B
file to open up white is is gonna hit
much faster black says you know what if
you're gonna be faster if if the things
are going to open up on the Kings side
let me at least make sure the Queen's
are exchanged this is what black does
offers a queen exchange Queen e4
like continues to press on the Kings
side Queens are exchanged structure is
strained out some Knight d5 one more pop
quiz light to move what move would you
play in this position feel free to pause
the video okay this is likely another
tough test this isn't a tactical
situation much more technical moment in
the game Caruana
are extremely Karlsson replies in a best
way computer thinks that this is best
rook e2g one now why is this move played
well even though the Queen's aren't on
the board white still has thoughts of
attacking the black King and you want to
keep pieces on the board if you're
trying to attack also it's important to
recognize that these ponds at the moment
they seem pretty invasive right they're
pretty close to the black King if things
become a bit too simplified it may be
the case that they turn hmm they become
a bit more of a liability than an asset
to be a bit careful as the aggressor in
this position simplify the position too
much and maybe these Kings side pawns
white pawns become vulnerable well
seeing a couple tiny examples later on
of how this can eggs take shape exactly
so from here rookie six preparing to
double computer isn't a big fan of this
move it's an all right move prefers rook
to e2 in some lines the rook is
accessible to a punch after g5 this is
where black makes a mistake
playing move Knight to e7 at first
glance it seems reasonable with the move
g5 f5 is a big gap and black is looking
to hop right to it given given just a
little bit of time black could be the
side who is better all of a sudden so
for example white on move if white just
says you know what let me improve the
King just a tiny bit it's an endgame my
king you'll be safe here king c2 black
would be better with Knight to f5 this
is either even or yeah I think I think I
would prefer to be black here I really
like this knight on f5 it's far more it
would be far more valuable than just
three point piece it's a good defender
and attacker from this post white
doesn't have that white doesn't spend
this time with King to c2 but instead
makes this timely capture on h6 and this
is probably the most interesting moment
of the event G takes h6
this move places Caruana in a think
maybe about a 7 8 minute think and
during his time thinking something
interesting happened at the st. Louis
chess club in Scholastic Center where
this game is being played there is a
confessional booth and Carlsen felt
pretty confident at this moment in the
game and rightly so the computer has
this as pawn plus advantage for white
and yeah carlson entered this
confessional booth and didn't say a word
but rather made a gesture that certainly
indicated he felt he was winning and
well let's see how play develops from
here a confident carlson at this moment
in the game why well black is certainly
finding it difficult to make some
accurate moves ninety-seven was not a
good choice black does however follow up
with the series of best moves has to
proceed with caution f6
excuse me f5 is throwing a punch at the
rook one wrong move and black is dead
meat if you want to see an example of
this you would take a pawn in the game
rook h7 was played if you take the pawn
it's game over
Knight g4 and let's say rook takes pawn
is met with Knight h6 and there goes the
rook you're not even getting the
exchange back because there'd be a
discovered attack against the King and
this is a way that you could actually
have the game and as mate check
checkmate
so in short at this moment rook takes
pawn is poison and playing to f6 is no
good either because of Knight g4 and
where's the rook going same story after
takes Knight h6 the rook is lost
black would get the get the knight back
in this case but white is +2 so the rook
has to go to h6 h7 and from here we have
the move Knight g4 there's Knight g4
there's also f6 computer seems to be
about equal ish you know kind of ways
- those moves the same there's a
difference you know by playing f6 right
now the knight has to make a move you
have to go to either d5 or f5 but by
playing Knight g4 right now and after
King to h8 f6 in the game there's a new
square for the knight Knight g8 White is
still better and it seems like Black has
extra passive to be sure you know just
kind of like setting up the pieces for
the next game Knight GA Bishop f8 but
black is black is hanging in there still
you know fighting for that f6 square
negating the knight that's on g4 and you
know even though the knight is back home
it's doing a good job controlling not
only the knight on g4 but also the rock
on g1 the knight doesn't have a good
forward move what's this guy doing ng
one district doesn't move what's this
rook dunya in the corner stubborn
defense by black in a difficult position
finding tough moves black RX me white
takes on g7 at this stage this is where
the advantage is basically thrown away
by white one of the moves computer likes
is Bishop to g5 keeping this tension and
after let's say rook to e8 playing rook
to h2 rookie 6 just getting some moves
in repositioning like this these aren't
the most natural moves to be making for
white but basically computer wants to
hold this tension on the f6 point
doesn't want to promote either the
bishop or the rook to the g7 square so
as it's played out in this game after
the move Knight to g8 Carlson takes on
g7 rook takes and now Bishop to e3
looking to get on this nice diagonal
that is shot down with c5 and Bishop f4
rook e8 f5 d5 or IDE up
one rook is off and now this pawn right
here at this point with one rook off
there isn't an attack against the King
so earlier I was pointing out how if you
simplify the position a little bit too
much you know these the pawns on the
Kings side will now there's only one
this guy an h5 can maybe start to be
seen more so as a liability so rookie
six in this game Knight d5 Knight f6
casing point right here if you go for
one more exchange white on move if white
captures the knight one more pieces off
this is pawn a liability or an asset
this is an asset looks to me this is a
liability the bishop is under fire the
bishop would have to move here you can
see rook to f5 you don't want to go
completely passive like this defending
so white would have to be careful if he
trade too much could be on Y could be on
his heels so what do we have in replied
in Knight f6 I have Knight c7 rookie to
Knight b5 striking at two points the
rook returns to defend and we have a
little bit of a a back and forth here
okay not not just yet rook to f1 in this
position if the knight captures the pawn
on a7 black can't improve the King and
then think about taking the pawn next so
taking the pawn straight away would be a
bad move a losing move because of rook
h1 and the night is going to fall but if
in this position Carlson takes the pawn
King h7 what are you doing about Knight
takes pawn if you defend it with rook to
h1 there's Knight to d5 the black pieces
are pretty active here Bishop reacts
Bishop h6 the
Bishop's can be exchanged and yeah this
pond is probably gonna fall pretty soon
try to get the night back in the
ballgame I think this pond could fall
whenever hit with the night maybe even
scooped up with the rook there's also a
passer light would need to be on the
lookout form if it gets too simplified
this pawn is a certain liability what do
we have in this game rook f1 King GA if
the rook returns black will gladly
improve the king so this little back and
forth if white tries for something like
that
is just going to help the black king so
from here we have Knight c7 rookie to
Knight b5 rookie six and you see where
this game is going Carlson is not going
to pick up the ape on this one is ending
with a threefold repetition a draw on
board if white wants to pick up the pawn
in this position black will simply knock
out the rook pawn as well nothing really
to play for in this position this Knight
is more out of play than this one here
the black King is probably going to find
it a little bit easier to get activated
in this end game than the white King F
pawn has already passed and there are no
white pawns that are passed it's not
really a path to go down
playing his white so earlier on entering
that confession confessional booth
Carlson was confident thinking he was
winning but in the end I was not able to
convert I'm not sure what kind of
psychological impact this will have this
game here will have on the players
Carlsen had his chances
in a difficult spot found some accurate
moves Carlson was confident at one point
but didn't convert what are your
thoughts about this what are your
thoughts about the upcoming World Chess
Championship match feel free to leave a
comment below who do you think will win
what will be the match score the tale
the tape on this one if you're curious
this is what it looks like some
advantage throughout just a tiny one for
Carlson and right around this stage the
96-97 this is where yeah after this
capture G takes h6 moved 25 that's when
Carlson went into the confessional booth
didn't say a word
but yeah just made a gesture that said
I'm winning but yet Caruana ended up
defending well and it evened out in the
end
draw on board inaccuracies mistakes
blunders for each side 16 average sent
upon loss for each side so anyhow as
usual feel free to leave any feedback to
this game in the comment section below
I hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away that's all for now
take care bye
you